yes for when welcome to this video plain
black against Prince panic really
hendrix so huh I don't know what is he
doing them trying this line he's
probably going D for Queen D for usually
plays Bishop b5 Sicilian some this is
one of the reasons for okay 46 let me
see three now just counted certainly not
bad how is this plate Jim probably with
e6
ok will seem I'm a little bit flowy and
development wise
everyone Bishop g5 we have the so called
web structure with the pawn on d4 and d5
and i think i'd like to prevent the
bishop coming down it looks very equal
to share with this completely
symmetrical points but often there are
little things that are actually
different like here with the han caido
i'm having some pressure on this pawn
but also a little bit behind and
development some curious and sugar for
am I think I definitely want to get out
of the center ha i think really don't
really feel like this help all that much
frame i mean yeah that was quite some
pressure on default
maybe 95 attacking my c6 pause
hmm
jump this g5 v to anything I have my
doubts I actually really like to compete
developments are now the policy six and
then the square on c5 that that is the
main thing that why displaying form so i
can write a for this very sensible okay
well i can go creature a five trying to
wait wait wait wait wait and why not
this i can actually play this so let's
do it d 4 is under some pressure as well
i know it I'm opening up the bishop and
like opening up everything must be ok at
least I should not be worse should be
five looks interesting though well I can
take okay I don't need to take I cannot
do this I was started with I wanted to
take and then d 4 but I can play the 4
immediately so we are taking on c3 isn't
great so correct this 94 probably I can
take a 2 at the end which might or might
not be good hit hello would see
so grab Jim I can take him on a Jew he
does not have anything great against
this I feel so let's do it I'm not sure
g4 may be here for him
maybe a species I've got Bishop t5
against chief one that's a good idea
anyway I get this in be 55 challenging
the e4 night now a bit ahead on the
clock that's also quite useful I still
at the webcam star and King I've looked
at this for changes ages yesterday and
it's I still have it air conflicts and
all things are not going all that well
all kinds of technical problems and
stuff kind of also affects my play a
little bit because I've always somewhat
pissed off when I play across and I
clear and the connection is bad the
video is bad the sound is bad whatever
and I invest time trying to fix it but
and what does that can't crap us I mean
it was working fine for a long time and
yeah now i have the stutter for no
particular reason so okay so this ending
I'm doubled porn up so objectively
speaking it's a draw can try to gain a
bit of space and I mean there's no
particular reason to make this draw you
can still fly around a little bit but
okay if I get to have to actually have
some chances here but it looks unlikely
[Music]
okay you can just stay there and I
cannot do all that much
okay I wonder can I try to roll off 02
III somehow I just need to get go get to
III m
I go King 5 you always checks me only
true king before and then look II for
this is the thing I would like to get to
III and it still is kind of interesting
okay and if you take that six let's
check here and actually losing the F
power since I don't get to III time
morning mr. anything else where I can
try to get there
[Music]
I can do around there with the Rupert
but probably doesn't help at all check I
cannot do it all office and I will go
[ __ ] no myself gain wrong get or do
anything else so um yeah maybe maybe
there was something but I don't know but
when I when I got this default doesn't
seem to be the case general computer is
giving equal all the time k my route d8
was better now it's ugly it wrong anyway
now you cannot do anything I even with
them even if the pawn structure would be
like perfect for black here you just
cannot win one point it's not enough
yeah okay thanks for watching now will
again waste like half an hour to do
something about the webcam thanks for
watching